L'Afghanistan est un pays qui est en guerre depuis plusieurs décénnies.
Il y a beaucoup de tueries.
Tous les jours,
une centaine de personnes sortent de chez eux
et n'y retournent jamais.
Il y a un attentat en moyenne tous les deux jours en ce moment.
Les médecins restent en permanence au chevet des enfants.
On a eu beaucoup d'enfants  tués par les bombardements
et on est très certainement dans un conflit  qui a fait plusieurs centaines de milliers de morts.
Ce sont nos enfants, ils sont notre avenir.
Et ils souffrent de telles blessures à cet âge-là.
Nous demandons aux pays étrangers  d'aider l'Afghanistan,
mais pas une aide  qui nous rende malheureux.
Je vous emmène dans un pays en plein chaos
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi malheureusement ça risque de durer.
D'accord. Donc on a une heure.
Une heure, oui.
D'accord, allons-y.
Au mois de septembre 2019, je suis parti pour Brut
en Afghanistan avec le vidéaste Leo Grasset de la chaîne Youtube DirtyBiology.
On s'est rendus là-bas pour vous montrer comment la guerre impacte le quotidien des civils,
et pendant notre mission, il y a eu plusieurs attentats.
On est d'abord allés à Kandahar, une ville particulièrement  instable au sud du pays pour rencontrer Wali,
un médecin du Comité international de la Croix-Rouge qui soigne des blessés de guerre depuis plus de 15 ans.
Pour le nombre de patients que nous avons,
cet espace ne suffit pas.
- C'est un peu trop petit. - Oui, trop petit.
Parfois, on effectue le triage ici.
- Quand on a encore plus de patients... - Quand il y a beaucoup de victimes... C'est ici ?
Oui, c'est ici, dans cet espace.
Lorsqu'il y a une grosse explosion en ville, on reçoit plus de 50 patients.
Alors tout le personnel de l'hôpital vient ici.
Il y a des blessures par balle, par mine antipersonnel etc. Ils sont tous amenés là.
Combien de traumas avez-vous par jour ?
Dans le service principal, plus de 300.
- 300 ? - 300...
- En un jour ? - Oui.
Ensuite,
pour 40 à 50 patients on fait des opérations chirurgicales.
Ça, c'est le garçon qui a été blessé par une mine.
Quel âge a-t-il ?
Il a environ 12 ans.
Dans combien de jours pensez-vous qu'il va se réveiller ?
Cela va dépendre de la gravité de la blessure.
C'est un patient dans un état critique
parce qu'il a des plaies de schrapnel  dans l'abdomen et dans le crâne.
Son état s'améliore, il va mieux qu'avant.
Comment arrivez-vous à garder vos distances, à ne pas être affecté par tout ça ?
Ça me fait beaucoup de peine.
Ce sont nos enfants, ils sont notre avenir.
Et ils souffrent de telles blessures à cet âge-là.
Alors pensez à son avenir, à ce qui va lui arriver...
On espère qu'un jour ils aillent à l'école,  pour apprendre et avoir un avenir.
On n'a plus d'espoir, c'est difficile, mais que pouvons-nous y faire ?
Des enfants blessés comme le petit Aghawali il y en a des dizaines de milliers en Afghanistan,
et malheureusement ça fait un moment que ça dure parce que le pays est en guerre depuis plus de 40 ans.
Là, avec Léo on vient d'arriver dans le département de malnutrition.
Il y a 37 enfants qui sont pris en charge,
parce qu'ils sont gravement sous-alimentés et en sous-poids,
certains sont même en urgence vitale.
Ici les enfants sont vraiment très fragiles,
pour la plupart ce sont des nourrissons, ils ont entre 6 mois et 1 an et demi
donc il y a tout le temps des médecins  pour les surveiller, 24 heures sur 24,
pour s'assurer qu'ils vont bien.
Comme vous le voyez, c'est un bébé, et elle a 18 mois.
Mais malheureusement, elle ne pèse que 5,8 kilogrammes.
Ce qui est très bas pour son âge : à 18 mois, elle devrait  peser au moins 12 kilos.
Si vous la regardez bien,  vous remarquerez qu'ici, elle n'a pas de cheveux.
Elle a perdu ses cheveux.
C'est l'un des signes distinctifs de malnutrition.
Si vous regardez ici sur son corps, vous voyez les côtes qui ressortent.
Donc ça veut dire qu'elle a perdu ses muscles.
La plupart des enfants qui souffrent de malnutrition et qui arrivent à l'hôpital,
qui sont pris en charge, médicalement, ont de très grandes chances de s'en sortir,
les maladies qui pourraient aggraver la situation  de malnutrition, comme des diarrhées ou des fièvres,
sont immédiatement traitées, et ensuite, une fois qu'ils sont stabilisés,
les médecins donnent aux bébés un lait riche en nutriments
qui leur permet de retrouver rapidement une croissance normale.
Je travaille dans ce service depuis 15 ans.
Je suis heureux de travailler avec eux, mais quand je les regarde, je suis triste.
Je pense que l'amélioration de la situation n'est pas entre nos mains,
c'est à un niveau au-dessus de nous.
Historiquement, l'Afghanistan a d'abord été envahi par l'Union soviétique, à la fin des années 70,
une guerre qui va durer pendant 10 ans, jusqu'en 1989,
et avant l'intervention américaine à partir de 2001,
il y a eu la prise de pouvoir d'un groupe armé appelé les talibans.
Les talibans sont un groupe islamiste, rigoristes sur le plan moral,
avec une vision inspirée de l'Islam politique.
Ils prennent le pouvoir en 1996, ils mettent en place un régime qui va durer jusqu'en 2001,
ils accueillent pendant cette période un groupe armé international appelé Al-Qaïda,
responsable en septembre 2001 des attentats sur les tours jumelles à New York.
Peu importe le temps que ça prendra,
l'heure de la justice viendra.
Les États-Unis soutenus par de nombreuses nations,
vont se rendre justice face aux terroristes en Afghanistan.
À partir de là, les États-Unis prennent la décision,  avec un mandat des Nations Unies,
d’intervenir dans le pays en octobre 2001.
Le régime taliban est renversé, remplacé  par un nouveau régime qui s’installe à partir de 2002,
jusqu’à la situation actuelle, avec un affrontement très violent
entre le régime issu de l’intervention, à Kaboul,  et l’insurrection talibane, de l’autre côté.
Les talibans m'ont arrêté. J'ai stoppé ma moto.
Ils m'ont tiré dessus pour me tuer. J'avais très mal. Ils ont cru qu'il m'avaient tué.
J'ai très mal. Je souffre et ça me gêne beaucoup.
Ils t'ont donné des médicaments ?
J'ai eu des injections, mais pas de cachets. J'ai très mal.
Je serais heureux si l'Afghanistan était en sécurité, si les talibans partaient,
pour qu'on puisse vivre avec nos enfants,
et les nourrir en paix.
La plupart des victimes sont des civils,
mais on a aussi des soldats, la police vient ici.
La police, et les talibans ? Tout le monde vient ici ?
Tout le monde vient ici. C'est un endroit neutre.
Pour les talibans, pour tout le monde, c'est un lieu ouvert.
Et c'est ça en fait qui est incroyable,
les ennemis se retrouvent dans le même hôpital pour être soignés,
il y a donc ici des soldats de l'armée afghane et des talibans,
ou, en tout cas, des soutiens des talibans.
L'un d'eux a accepté de nous parler,
écoutez-bien son discours parce que ça permet de comprendre la situation actuelle en Afghanistan.
Je viens de la ville de Parade,
dans la région de Gulistan.
Mon oncle est malade et à l'hôpital. Je suis venu pour lui rendre visite.
Il n'y aura plus de problèmes en Afghanistan quand les Américains auront quitté le pays.
On veut que la loi de l'islam soit appliquée, que les lois islamiques soient établies.
Ça va être calme et la sécurité reviendra
dès que les Américains quittent l'Afghanistan,  nous serons tranquilles.
La manière dont les militaires américains ont agi, notamment au début des années 2000,
a provoqué une indignation chez les Afghans.
Il faut bien comprendre que dans les premières années, en raison des attentats du 11 septembre,
les militaires américains reçoivent carte blanche, en particulier les forces spéciales américaines,
qui avaient pour mission de traquer et de tuer les militants d'Al-Qaïda et les militants talibans.
Ils ont mis en place des milices dans tout le pays
qui ont torturé des gens en les suspectant d'être talibans.
Et beaucoup d'images de ces actes de tortures montrant la violence et les exactions
des forces spéciales américaines ont fuitées sur les réseaux sociaux,
notamment, cette vidéo,
elle a été révélée en 2013 par le journaliste d'investigation américain Matthieu Aikins.
A l'époque, la cour pénale internationale  avait même essayé de lancer une procédure d'enquête
contre les crimes de guerre commis en Afghanistan,
mais elle n'avait finalement pas abouti.
Donc beaucoup de gens ont été tués, ou torturés, sans avoir jamais participé au mouvement taliban,
sans jamais avoir été dans Al-Qaïda,
Au bout de quelques années, le rejet des Etats-Unis est devenu très fort. Très très fort.
Tant qu'ils seront là, le feu ne sera pas éteint  et le gouvernement ne pourra pas se mettre en place.
Personne n'aime les Américains.
Nous ne voulons pas de l'amitié des Américains.  Partez ! On veut notre islam.
Laissez-nous tranquilles. Avec notre islam.
En fait il est impossible de comprendre les talibans et la situation afghane,
si on omet, comme on le fait trop souvent, le fait que  c'est une société qui a passé 40 ans dans la guerre civile.
C'est une société dont 80% de la population est née dans la guerre.
La popularité des talibans dans les campagnes, elle s'explique par leur capacité à exercer le droit,
à mettre en place des tribunaux dont les décisions sont respectées.
D'un côté leurs juges sont reconnus  comme des juges islamiques,
ils sont reconnus comme des gens dont les décisions s'inspirent des textes islamiques,
et leur deuxième avantage,  c'est le fait que leurs décisions sont respectées,
que les gens ont peur de désobéir, car les punitions, pour ceux qui désobéissent aux jugements talibans,
sont extrêmement sévères.
Les gens sont bannis, les maisons sont détruites, voire les gens sont tués.
Cette capacité qu'ont les talibans  de dissuader toute forme de désobéissance,
elle est en fait un des fondements de leur popularité.
Il contrôle sous la voiture, s'il y'a pas des explosifs.
On part de Kandahar pour aller à Kaboul avec un avion du CICR.
Kaboul est devenue une des villes les plus dangeureuses au monde.
C'est une mégapole de 5 millions d'habitants où
toutes les modalités de vie sont imprégnées de la guerre.
Fais attention...
Les attentats sont monnaie courante, ils sont devenus extrêmement fréquents,
et énormément d'Afghans ont perdu un de leurs proches, voire plusieurs,
voire, parfois, des familles balayées par les attentats
parce qu'ils passaient au mauvais moment au mauvais endroit.
Bonjour.
- Comment allez-vous ? - Bien et vous ?
- Vos documents sont à jour ? - Oui.
- Quels documents sont à jour ? Lesquels sont périmés ? - Ils sont tous à jour.
- Ils sont de quelle nationalité ? - Ils sont français.
- Ils sont journalistes ou de l'ambassade ? - Ils sont journalistes.
- Vous pouvez passer. - À votre service.
La guerre est partout.
On a des blocs de béton qui sont en fait des blocs
qu'on appelle anti-blast qui servent à empêcher les attentats,
qui sont posés un peu partout.
Des nombreuses rues sont fermées, tout le centre-ville est en fait fermé
pour laisser sa place aux bases occidentales  et aux ambassades occidentales.
Depuis qu'on est arrivé, il y a eu plusieurs attentats.
dont deux qui se sont produits  à Kaboul et qui ont fait des dizaines de morts,
donc la situation est extrêmement tendue.
Les principales cibles à chaque fois sont souvent les militaires,
et parfois quand on a le temps de discuter avec eux,
ils nous laissent un peu filmer.
En fait, on se fait accompagner  par un policier qui nous escorte
visiblement parce que le contexte sécuritaire est assez compliqué.
Donc nous on représente un peu des cibles.
On peut filmer ici ?
Eh toi !
- Je vais porter plainte contre lui. - Pourquoi ? Qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ?
Il filmait des gens en marchant.  Il faut demander avant de filmer.
- Qu'est ce qu'on fait ? - Rien.
- Je lui ai déjà demandé de ne pas filmer la police. - Peut-être, il n'a pas fait attention.
- Désolé.
Le contexte est vraiment  tendu encore une fois
une des conséquences de tout ça, c' est  qu'on ne peut pas filmer les checkpoints de sécurité...
Ils sont très, très tendus vis-à-vis de ça et donc là, on était en train de filmer un truc,
on a fait un très léger mouvement de caméra,
et le mec est venu nous voir  et il a fallu discuter pendant 5 minutes
pour savoir ce que l'on faisait etc.
C'est dans ce contexte extrêmement tendu qu'on est allés à la rencontre d'un médecin exceptionnel,
il s'appelle Alberto Cairo et il s'occupe d'un centre de rééducation
où les victimes de la guerre peuvent se reconstruire grâce au sport.
Nous allons au gymnase,  un endroit où l'on fait du sport.
Ça fait combien de temps que vous faites ça ?
Ça a probablement commencé en 2010, donc presque 9 ans.
Et ça s'améliore,  de plus en plus de personnes viennent.
Maintenant, nous avons 650 joueurs de basket.
Presque 200 sont des femmes,
ce qui est plutôt un succès, je suis content.
Et tout le monde est handicapé ? Oh, oui, oui, oui...
Parfois, je joue aussi.
Je m'assoie sur le fauteuil roulant et je joue avec eux mais ils sont trop forts pour moi.
Je ne peux pas du tout rivaliser  avec eux de toute façon.
- Salam aleykoum - Salam aleykoum !
C'est l'équipe féminine de basket en fauteuil roulant de Kaboul,
elles sont au taquet.
Pour l'instant, elles s'entraînent,  elles sont en train de s'échauffer.
Tout à l'heure, on va les voir  en train de faire un match.
Mais c'est vraiment impressionnant.
Certaines des filles et moi-même faisons partie de l'équipe nationale.
Le basket, ça fait partie de la vie de toutes les filles qui sont ici.
Avec le basket, nous voulons montrer  que les femmes d'Afghanistan sont fortes.
Les filles d'Afghanistan travaillent,  font du sport, font des études.
Et elles sortent de l'Afghanistan pour les matches  afin de montrer une image plus sympathique,
une image pacifique, une image meilleure du pays.
Une roquette a frappé ma maison. J'étais assise derrière la fenêtre.
J'ai été touchée par des éclats du lance-roquettes.
J'ai été blessée et j'ai subi plusieurs opérations. Mon frère a été tué sur le coup.
Les filles m'ont proposé de jouer  avec elles au basket,
donc je vais m'installer sur un fauteuil, et puis je vais tenter de jouer avec elles.
Je pense que je vais galérer.
Ils m'ont attaché complètement pour que
je sois vraiment, que je fasse corps avec le fauteuil.
Il n'y a pas de freins,  tu dois t'arrêter en utilisant tes mains.
Okay ! C'est parti !
Elles ont la forme, hein... Parce que : c'est usant !
C'est vraiment usant.
En fait, je suis hyper impressionné par les filles,
parce que elles sont vraiment  à fond dans la compétition et tout.
Il y en a une qui s'est renversée un moment, et puis, elle s'est relevée direct.
Vraiment, elles sont dans leur bain,  leur truc, Elles sont... Détermination 100%. Et...
Elles sont là pour gagner  et te mettre une grosse race, tu vois.
- Comment était le match ? - Très cool.
- Ça t'a plu ? - Oui, c'est génial.
Tu es très douée.
- L'équipe. - L'équipe est douée.
Quelle idée y a-t-il derrière le fait d'entraîner et de faire faire du sport aux gens ?
Il y a quelques années,
je me suis demandé...
Est-ce que c'est nécessaire de commencer  un projet sportif, dans un pays comme l'Afghanistan,
où il manque encore tant de choses ?
Et la réponse était oui !
Les gens devraient attendre quoi ?
La paix ?
C'est un moyen de leur redonner  la confiance qu'ils n'ont plus.
Donc, l'idée, c'est de leur prouver de nouveau qu'ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent,
ils peuvent faire plein de choses, profiter de leurs vies.
C'est quelque chose qui doit être fait maintenant,
malgré l'état de l'Afghanistan.